La culture japonaise est pour nous Occidentaux,
le summum de l’exotisme. Raffinement, discipline,
poésie, on pourrait dérouler à l’infini les
lieux communs sur cette civilisation qui semble,
sur la plupart des aspects, aux antipodes de la
nôtre. L’ouverture au monde du Japon au milieu
du XIXe siècle, a ainsi profondément
marqué le grand public européen,
qui a découvert d’un seul coup cette culture
si étrange et séduisante. A l’époque où le
Japon se convertit rapidement à la
modernité occidentale, la peinture,
la mode et même les jardins d’Occident se
teintent, eux, de romantisme japonisant.
Et s’il est un aspect de cette culture qui nous
étonne tout particulièrement, c’est son rapport
à la nature. L’omniprésence des motifs de fleurs,
la poésie décrivant les paysages avec mélancolie,
la contemplation fataliste des éléments déchaînés
et la vénération des rochers ou des montagnes,
ont offert à la modernité européenne de quoi
réfléchir. On a même souvent écrit que la
différence entre nature et culture n’existait tout
simplement pas au Japon. Sans aller jusque-là,
il est vrai qu’en ce qui concerne la perception
de la nature, le contraste est saisissant.
La nature, que l’on pense être une
donnée universelle, puisqu’en dehors des cultures
humaines, est en fait, comme tout le reste, saisie
à travers le prisme de la culture. La perception
de la nature, son appréhension, diffère donc
beaucoup selon les civilisations. La nôtre, en
Occident, est modelée par différentes influences.
C’est tout d’abord l’Antiquité grecque, qui
construit une solide frontière entre nature
et culture. Le terme de phusis, qui a donné
“physique”, désigne en grec l'essence ou le
principe d'une chose. Le philosophe Aristote
étend cette notion de phusis à l'ensemble
du vivant, et cela devient synonyme de nature.
L’anthropologue Philippe Descola qui a consacré
son œuvre à l’étude des rapports entre nature et
culture insiste sur cet événement
Cependant les humains font
encore partie de la nature pour les Grecs.
Les Romains accentuent cette séparation,
mais c’est véritablement la pensée
chrétienne qui coupe l’humain de lanature.
Dans la mythologie chrétienne, les
humains sont extérieurs et supérieurs à la
nature. Créé pour régner sur le reste de
la création, l’humain est, par définition,
surnaturel. Cette singularité est réaffirmée et
accentuée pendant tout le Moyen-âge. La nature
est repoussée, à grands coups de défrichements,
d’assèchement des marais, puis avec l’émergence
de la science moderne, elle est soumise,
comme tout le reste, à une rationalisation.
Et cette opposition nature/culture
devient un attribut de la modernité.
Pourtant cette séparation soi-disant universelle
n'est l'apanage que de l'Occident et pas depuis
très longtemps. De nombreuses autres manières de
percevoir la nature sont possibles. Et le Japon
en est un parfait exemple.
Au Japon, les notions qui se rapprocheraient
le plus de notre opposition entre nature et
culture sont celles de yama et sato. Le mot yama,
signifiant montagne, peut aussi désigner la forêt,
ou l’espace inhabité de manière générale. Sato
désigne au contraire le village, l’espace habité.
Mais cela n’est pas comparable à la dichotomie
nature/culture ou sauvage/domestique fondée en
Occident. Au Japon, la montagne n’est pas un
espace sauvage, puisqu’elle est habitée par des
esprits et des divinités. Ces divinités habitent
la montagne ou la plaine en fonction des saisons.
Au printemps, elles descendent des montagnes pour
devenir des divinités des rizières, et remontent
à l’automne, pour retrouver leur “temple du fond”,
un lieu difficilement accessible le plus souvent,
qui constitue leur demeure principale.
L’autre mot utilisé par les Japonais pour
parler de la nature est le mot shinzen, qu’on peut
traduire par “ce qui va de soi”. En conséquence,
on laisse la nature tranquille, puisqu’elle
s’autorégule, qu’elle n’a pas besoin des
humains. Dans la culture japonaise, la
nature est donc connotée positivement,
contrairement à notre “état de nature” et toute
la rhétorique du contrôle des pulsions naturelles.
Les monastères bouddhistes qui s’établissent
dans les montagnes japonaises à partir du XIIe
siècle poursuivent ainsi un objectif complètement
différent des monastères chrétiens en Occident.
Les moines chrétiens se consacrent à
défricher, mettre en valeur la nature,
pour exorciser le sauvage en quelque sorte. Au
Japon, les moines ne veulent pas transformer la
montagne mais au contraire éprouver une forme de
fusion avec l’environnement, qui est pour eux,
la garantie du salut. Le caractère qui sert à
écrire montagne sert également pour désigner
les monastères, ce qui dit bien qu’ils
partagent tous les deux un aspect sacré.
La montagne ou la forêt sont donc des
compléments du monde villageois au Japon,
pas son antithèse. Cette manière de
penser la nature aura des conséquences
sur la préservation de l’environnement à notre
époque, mais j’en reparlerai tout à l’heure.
Mais d’où vient cette spécificité japonaise ?
Pourquoi leurs moines contemplent les roseaux
en composant des poèmes plutôt que de
planter de l’orge pour brasser de la
bière ? C’est une question que se sont posés
beaucoup d’intellectuels au XIXe siècle,
au moment où le Japon s'ouvre au monde. Et
l’une des théories en vogue à cette époque
est la théorie déterministe.
Le déterminisme est une théorie qui émerge à
la fin du XIXe siècle et qui postule que les
cultures et les individus sont des produits
de leur environnement. Autrement dit,
si les visions qu’ont les Européens et les
Japonais de leur environnement sont différentes,
c’est que leurs environnements sont différents.
Ainsi la nature plutôt docile et le climat tempéré
de l’Europe auraient favorisé un traitement très
rationnel des éléments naturels. Au contraire,
la nature japonaise, plus indisciplinée à cause
du relief et du climat extrêmement contrasté
de l'archipel, aurait encouragé un esprit
romantique admirant le désordre et intervenant
le moins possible dans le domaine naturel.
Il est vrai que l’archipel japonais a des
dispositions climatiques exceptionnelles. Il
possède une amplitude de latitude équivalente
à une zone allant de Cuba jusqu’au Québec. Il
y a par ailleurs une opposition nette entre le
Japon de l’Endroit, ouvert sur le Pacifique
et le Japon de l’Envers donnant sur la mer
du Japon. La délimitation des saisons y
est particulièrement abrupte, avec un été
caniculaire et un hiver très rigoureux. Les îles
reçoivent aussi énormément de précipitations,
avec la mousson et les typhons saisonniers. Le
relief très accidenté a aussi permis à la forêt
de se maintenir jusqu’à aujourd’hui, ce qui fait
qu’elle couvre toujours les deux tiers du pays.
En suivant le raisonnement déterministe,
ce seraient donc ces conditions naturelles
exceptionnelles qui seraient à l’origine
de la perception de la nature au Japon. Et
il y a sans doute un fond de vrai là-dedans.
Quand on prend un typhon sur la tronche tous
les ans et qu’on peut pas faire dix bornes
sans rencontrer un volcan, on a sans doute
pas le même rapport à la nature qu’en Picardie.
Mais cette explication n’est pas suffisante. Le
déterminisme gomme en effet complètement
la dynamique propre des civilisations. A
en croire cette théorie, toutes les cultures
confrontées à des climats similaires devraient
se ressembler comme deux gouttes d’eau. Or,
bien sûr, ce n’est pas le cas. De mêmes climats
voient apparaître des religions différentes, des
idéologies différentes, etc. Bref, il n’y a pas
de règle aussi simple que ça en la matière.
D’autant que la théorie déterministe a aussi
servi de justification au racisme au début du XXe
siècle. En imaginant que le climat “vivifiant”
de l’Europe a plus stimulé la civilisation, le
britannique Ellsworth Huntington justifiait en
1915 dans la domination des Européens sur les
peuples des climats chauds, supposés ralentir
l’évolution. Le Français Hippolyte Taine avait
fait le même raisonnement dès le XIXe siècle. A
cette époque, on ne s’embarrasse pas trop
de précautions et on mélange allègrement
sciences naturelles et sciences sociales
dans un grand gloubi-boulga d’affirmations
invérifiables et de causalité douteuse.
On va donc laisser tout ça un peu de
côté. La nature japonaise ne ressemble pas
à la nature européenne, soit, mais il faut
surtout s’intéresser aux raisons historiques
et sociales pour comprendre d’où vient la
perception si particulière de la nature au Japon.
La religion japonaise est issue d’un syncrétisme,
c’est-à-dire d’un amalgame entre plusieurs
traditions. L’une d’entre elles est le shinto.
Shinto signifie “la voie des esprits”. Le terme
est emprunté au chinois avec shen, qui signifie
“esprit” et tao, “voie”, mais il s’agit bien
d’une religion locale. Plusieurs historiens
proposent de faire remonter cette tradition
religieuse à la culture Jômon qui s’étend
grosso-modo de 14 000 à 1 000 avant J.-C. C’est,
pour résumer rapidement, le Néolithique japonais.
Mais c’est surtout à l’époque suivante, le Yayoi
entre 1 000 avant et 300 après J.-C., qu’on peut
voir apparaître des éléments caractéristiques
de la religion shinto, notamment sa mythologie.
Dans cette mythologie, il existe un grand tout
originel, organisé sous la forme d’une trinité,
comme dans le christianisme ou l’hindouisme.
Le couple divin primordial, composé d’Izanagi
et Izanami en émerge, puis c’est au tour
des autres divinités secondaires. Mais la
mythologie shinto se distingue en fait par
l’absence d’une véritable anthropogonie,
l’humain ne tient pas de place particulière dans
la création. L’humain est parmi les vivants, parmi
les autres esprits qui peuplent l’environnement.
Car le shinto est en réalité un culte proche de
l’animisme, c’est-à-dire qui peuple la nature de
divinités et de toutes sortes d’esprits. Le mot
qu’emploient les Japonais pour ces divinités,
kami, n’est d’ailleurs pas très précis,
puisqu’il se réfère à tout ce qui dans
l’environnement inspire du mystère ou
semble relever d’une force supérieure.
Il y a donc un kami du vent, de la foudre,
etc. Tous les éléments naturels se voient dotés
d’une volonté, ils sont redoutés, mais peuvent
être amadoués grâce à des rituels. Certaines
montagnes, comme le mont Miwa, sont réputées
abriter une grande divinité. On construit alors un
sanctuaire à ses pieds pour attirer ses faveurs,
notamment l’eau nécessaire aux rizières, qui
descend de la montagne. Il n’y a donc pas de
limitation pour les formes dans lesquelles
peuvent s’incarner les divinités, arbre,
rocher, nuage, « tout est kami en puissance ».
Bon, j’ai pas trop le droit de passer un extrait,
mais de toute façon vous avez tous vu Princesse
Mononoké. Donc le gros sanglier vermoulu et
les bestioles bizarres de la forêt là qui
penchent la tête, c’est ça l’animisme japonais.
En résumé, le shinto est une religion floue. Pas
de prophète fondateur, pas de texte sacré, pas de
dogme officiel, ça nous change des monothéismes
occidentaux. Cette tradition est donc porteuse
d’une vision de la nature particulièrement
positive. C’est à travers la nature, qu’on peut
approcher le sacré et les forces supérieures.
Cette religion primitive du shinto se mêle
à partir du VIe siècle après J.-C. à des
influences étrangères. Les traditions chinoises,
taoïsme et confucianisme, ont elles aussi une
conception fondamentalement positive de la nature,
qui agit comme un refuge, une source de pureté et
de renouveau. Le bouddhisme, qui est une religion
d’origine indienne, se mélange à ces conceptions
chinoises avant de débarquer au Japon et renforce
la sacralité de la nature japonaise.
L'emploi du mot “paradoxe” est omniprésent pour
parler du Japon mais dans le cas de son rapport
à la nature, il est justifié. Le Japon glorifie
la nature, on l’a vu, mais il est devenu dans les
années 1960 le pays le plus pollué de la planète.
Lancé dans un développement industriel frénétique
après les dévastations de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale, le “miracle économique japonais”
s’est fait au détriment de l’environnement.
Alors je sais ce que vous allez me dire,
chez nous aussi. Mais paradoxalement, le Japon,
bien qu’en ayant cette idée d’une nature sacrée
profondément enracinée dans sa culture, n’a
pas mieux protégé son environnement que nous.
L'idéologie de la protection écologique a, en
réalité, été en grande partie importée d'Occident.
Et cela ne vient pas seulement du fait que nous
ayons saccagé notre environnement plus tôt que
les Japonais. Il y a bien eu une absence
de prise en compte de l'environnement par
les politiques publiques japonaises. Des projets
prévoyaient notamment de combler une grande partie
de la “Méditerranée intérieure” du Japon pour
créer de vastes zones industrialo-portuaires,
ce qui aurait signifié la mort pure et
simple de l'écosystème marin et littoral.
Alors on peut penser que cette destruction de
l’environnement est le fruit d'une acculturation
complète du Japon, de l’adoption du capitalisme
vorace à l'occidentale à partir du XIXe siècle.
Mais ce n’est pas l’opinion du géographe Augustin
Berque, qui veut chercher les raisons de ce
phénomène au cœur même de la culture japonaise.
Il fait remarquer que le gouvernement japonais,
durant l'ère Meiji, et surtout au début
du XXe siècle, s'est servi du sentiment
de nature pour cimenter l'unité nationale.
Le shinto est proclamé religion d’Etat, et
les lieux et paysages célèbres sont mis en avant
dans les manuels scolaires et dans la propagande
officielle. On se concentre sur quelques sites
naturels iconiques : le Fuji-yama et les monts
Mikasa par exemple. La beauté du pays devient
en quelque sorte une revendication identitaire.
Augustin Berque affirme finalement que le paysage
national officiel a effacé le paysage local. La
signification identitaire du paysage a ainsi
pris le dessus sur l'expérience individuelle,
sensible, des montagnes, des forêts et
des littoraux. C'est cette logique qui a
permis l'aménagement destructeur du territoire
après-guerre et conduit à la crise écologique.
Dans les décennies suivantes, la transformation
systématique du pays prive les habitants de
leurs souvenirs, de la vue du paysage, et
parfois même de l'accès à la mer, à cause des
terre-pleins prévus pour accueillir les usines
et entrepôts. Cette crise écologique est vécue
par de nombreux Japonais comme une véritable
crise identitaire. Le peuple japonais était en
train de perdre son partenaire de toujours,
la nature et les esprits qui la peuplent.
Ce n’est qu’à partir des années 1970
et en s’inspirant d’autres mouvements
de lutte occidentaux que des collectifs
locaux ont réagi. Le “mouvement habitant”
notamment s’est engagé dans la lutte pour la
réappropriation du milieu et s'est opposé aux
projets de construction qui n’envisageaient
le territoire que sous l’angle économique.
Vénérée ou saccagée, la nature japonaise est donc
sauvage et foisonnante ou au contraire, mise en
scène de manière obsessionnelle dans des jardins.
Comprendre la nature comme quelque chose “qui va
de soi”, a donc un peu aveuglé les Japonais. En
faisant confiance à la nature, ils ont peut-être
négligé l’influence humaine. Ou quand l’esprit
mercantile est plus fort que l’esprit de la forêt.
Il y aurait encore beaucoup à dire
sur la manière dont cette perception influence
l’Occident aujourd’hui, notamment à travers le
“new-age” et les nouvelles spiritualités qui
sont souvent d’inspiration asiatique. Mais
il se trouve que c’est justement le sujet de la
prochaine vidéo, donc je vous demande encore un
peu de patience. D’ici là RDV sur Instagram, je
vous propose ce dimanche à 11h de nous retrouver
en Live pour la lecture d’un passage du livre
d’Augustin Berque Le sauvage et l'artifice.